what is up everybody my name is prestige
and this little minecraft herobrine
survival anybody that's new this series
I'm doing any but its not New hello and
today we're going to go on a little
adventure because I just kind of want to
explore and see what's up with around
the house because I haven't been
mentioned that so if we see any awesome
cage will go explore them and yeah we're
gonna check out just all the stuff on my
house I should take some shears with me
to get early sheep and sometime soon I
shall definitely make a farm a farm of
animals and a form of wheat since I mean
bro all I'm pretty sup foo because I got
like three three kajillion cows and
these cabbage give me all the goods yeah
we got a desert over Hugh let's look for
a let's go looking for I just 82 520 are
let's look for a sand temples maybe we
can get some diamonds I want to click
some sand and I know I'm gonna want
glass oh is that yeah it's the same
temple awesome two seconds in to say I'm
going to find a saint a plan i found the
same temple who's boss all right now
let's get some cacti and do the break of
this and get very quick the shears like
whoa not sure what up up or whatever
so I got some sand I got some cactus so
I can grow them cactus let's pick up
that sugar cane as well y hope we can
get some diamonds I want some diamonds
so here's so mature game let's put the
sugar in there take the top so you
continue to grow all right let's eat
let's eat get them noms and replace my
broken shovel with the new shuffle I'm
gonna like like so much of the smoothies
materials I'm getting a little bit like
whoa it's pretty ominous let's get a
torch up in here all right now anybody
that doesn't know this what you got to
do here you gotta not go down there
because if you go down there then you
get hit by all bit then you land on a
TNT pressure plate and it blows up all
the goods and you with it so I know
exactly what we're going to do hopefully
no mobs to spawn down there it's not
sounded like it yeah see there's a
little pressure pride I'm sneaky devil
trying to blow us up whoo there we go
some lights and shop I just probably
disappear thing I'd love it it's not
good national good man break you so that
you cannot kill us all right check okay
lots of bones that'll be helpful I guess
mortar that'll be helping turn the farm
fire aspect won some gold golden
terrible terrible it's pretty bad but
terrible auto diamonds sadness we've got
a ton of bones and also something else
that you can get from these TNT bro imma
breaking with that oh yes tnc 10 2 which
is like you got to get them it's
beautiful all right now I'm going to
collect these goods unclick the chests
but it is just smoothing because i'm
going to click the stuff up there just
smooth out once i get for smooth
actually I get chisel that's chisel so
yes I do want that i want the chiseled
chiseled I'm getting some lag and I
don't know why it's good knowing it's
like terrible for steroids topic since I
won't want you guys to experience it
take these creeper faces this was a very
nice fine very nice and I think it's
going to be nighttime so we're going to
want to get home before nighttime and
yes / come next time nothing is my pick
to have another one they get duty I do
don't worry I want to use iron at the
very least last thing on the list I can
come back i really don't need wallet
much so yeah hmm i'll get some snow
later as well thank you now we gotta
hightail it back home take a sort out oh
yeah the problem they're gonna start
spawning going to shush bottom before we
get home but i'll be up to say creepy
responding screw your creeper who ya
make it to the house on the hair brown
will visit us again while we sleep was a
nice little surprise last time here Bryn
I know I called him hair brown when i
first read it so i think that's like i
have a natural tendency just to calm her
Brian because that was the first thing I
called him I don't think I heard anybody
say Hera Brian her and I just called
mayor Brian I think bridge people's hair
Oh skeleton think British people say
heron if you're British you know say
over and please don't take offense to
that I can't think we're in the clear
Hey okay let's sort this have one orange
wool saying so much new sensor chisels
and stone and sand oh my gosh all right
t-bones doodles of bones you you
I can throw my beefs in the cookers and
see if I get it yeah nope no chicken
that they're awesome are we going to
sleep and if hair brown visits us we're
going to be ready up we're in the clear
winner clear there is no hair brown
attack Oh [ __ ] creeper one sec one
sec I've got out of range of the fail
oh why not come visit me sometime he did
visit us in our sleep I know if I like
to uh put iron doors or what do you
think that'll stop him anymore than now
since right now he's getting in really
easy to get away from the house oh it
doesn't fail sprint dot yeah there we go
guess I'm gunpowder awesome I can mix my
own DNT get some more steak shamash take
homes I guess in Flint I can make some
more arrows and there is some Flint
right outside my house so I want to put
it up play these goods we got ten gold
so that's cool give me your flinch now
I'll show you guys a tactic it all go
I'll show you guys in sec I'm just going
to show you guys tactic to get Flint
before that stupid creeper pops is still
face up I really just don't want to pick
up that kool so up let's just patch this
up now since if I don't pageant now I'm
going to get lazy only 13 dirt I don't
think it's going to be enough to patch
it gotta get the MC patcher in here well
that's good enough for now so for gravel
you just place it and break it and
eventually we will get some a difference
there we go see where I got one Flint's
the very second I to do going to will
come on give me the Flint's yes two
friends i see when i get a Flynn a lot
of time don't get the grab a piece black
sometimes no really how many creepers
can spawn like seriously how many
creepers can spawn on me oh my gosh like
answer how many Chris Burt oh my god
it's like the fourth time I've been
blown up by creeper in the series hot
bag please we had enough pieces I need
to get me some cats I'm just gonna place
the catch-all outside of my house and
get some cats and dogs did both my phone
nuts off my Flint okay it's good oh wow
I guess I'm lot of stuff then well back
to rank 2 i'm not gonna be enchanted
anytime soon oh let's make some arrows
freaking annoying creepers
freakin heck man group's annoying is
crap hmm what to do what to do but to go
but sure that you should carry some
bones are me at all times in case I run
across from walls 11 should you get my
steak in which in my inventory thought
to back my Flint we didn't really go
adventure that much as soon as I hit the
cavern place I went back because I take
it but where's my axe to blow my axe for
creep it blowing on my axe think I'll
end this episode of the mines yeah yeah
and I can do that 222222 yeah I'm going
to fix the staircase probably off k
off-camera obviously we're gonna search
for some damage I think I ended my thing
on the perfect level level 11 haha yes
this is where we shall hunt for the
diamonds there's anything nope good so
any of you that don't know strip mining
is it kind of just get a line redstone
awesome strip mining working like a boss
you kind of just get to a line and you
just make a line of mining and thats
basically it's now a diamond can be like
later 10 to 16 so strip mining around
that area is kind of the best way to
find a DM lunch love wow you also got to
know that this is love level place that
were there can all just go back the
other way hahaha super lovey will not
trick me alright guys I'll probably in
the video here I hope you all enjoyed
this and if you if you made it this far
I really I do think the video deserves a
like and so please leave a like if you
enjoyed comment and subscribe if you're
new since i'll be doing more dish stuff
sugars umoran ashrams pio core awesomes
RRP shoppers probably the strip mine a
little more yeah do that